what we now see in the Middle East is the
same pattern of conquest with which we became
familiar during the period of 1945 to 1950
this involves taking over a nation by means
of indirect aggression that is under the cover
of a fomented civil strife the purpose is to
put into domestic control those whose real
loyalty is to the aggressor it was by such
means that the Communists attempted to take
over Greece in 1947 that effort was thwarted
by the Truman Doctrine it was by such means
that the Communists took over Czechoslovakia
in 1948 it was by such means that the Communists
took over the mainland of China in 1949 it was
by such means that the Communists attempted
to take over Korea and Indochina beginning
in 1950 I am well aware the landing of United
States troops in Lebanon could have some serious
consequences that is why this step was taken
only after the most serious consideration and
broad consultation I have however come to the
sober and clear conclusion that the action was
essential to the welfare of the United States
it was required to support the principles of
justice and international law upon which peace
and a stable international order depends we must
however be prepared to meet the situation whatever
be the consequences we can do so confident that we
strive for a world in which nations be they
great or be they small can preserve their
independence we're striving for an ideal which
is close to the heart of every American and for
which in the past many Americans have laid
down their to say these ideals is to serve
the cause of peace security and well-being
not only for us but for all men everywhere